[Music]
we have Rush's YouTube channel have s5
showcases her amazing domino chain
reaction here's how her Domino
obsessions gained her over 1 million
subscribers I was about 10 years old
when I first started getting to
dominance
I just got a set of $28 at my
grandparents house and I decided one day
to set them up knock him down and I
really liked how Excel I went on YouTube
search dominoes and I found a ton of
amazing videos that blew my mind one she
gets inspired by everything from pop
culture to other Domino filters I get a
lot of inspiration seeing what other
people are doing and then I think to
know how can I improve on this idea or
build build off of it to do something
even more creative
but mapping out thousands of dominoes is
no easy task most of her designs take
days to complete and they don't always
fall as planned it's sad to see your
worth fall over before it's completed
especially if you don't get it on film
have Esch posted her first video in 2009
but our videos didn't start taking off
until a few years later in 2013 she
posted a domino trick video that went
completely viral today the video has
over 76 million views since then she's
used Domino's to create everything from
detailed cartoon characters the
full-fledged continent so my setups they
have absolutely no planning I just start
placing dominoes and I keep going I see
like you know how can I make this
different how can I build a structure in
a new way or you know just add onto
something to make a little bit more
interesting she recently used 7,000
dominoes to cover this Marriott hotel
room
[Music]
after spending hours doing a project and
just see go exactly how you plan it's
just it's a really great feeling and
that's kind of like what I live for
I always get comments saying like my my
daughter or my son gone to two dollars
because of your videos and I just want
to thank you for that and that doesn't
really want my heart and it gives me a
purpose for why I actually do dominant
[Applause]
[Music]